digital learning right now is viewed as
an adjunct it's like a it's like a
whiteboard and a computer you know in
the classroom you pay for it out of a
separate fund it's not at the core of
learning for a reason monopolies don't
want to have direct competition Jeb Bush
former governor of Florida what is at
the absolute top of your education
reform list applying digital learning as
a transformative tool to disrupt the
public education system to make it more
child centered more customized more
robust more diverse and that would be
digital in traditional schools and new
schools that would just it's a game
changer if in my mind if you take if you
eliminate the barriers of entry for a
group of math teachers in Utah that have
a suite of algebra 1 algebra to geometry
courses that they could they could sell
to a school district in Florida where
they share the resources that come for
that child in a way that allows the
teacher in the classroom and they to
share the resources we could see an
explosion of learning and that would I
mean it would up I assume it with up
test score not even test scores but
knowledge and it would decrease costs or
it's scalable it's higher quality it
would you could benchmark it to
world-class kind of standards and
expectations and and it would be a way
that you know instead of saying you get
your digital learning only if you're
homeschooled or you know the only can
get a private this would be a way to
create a more hybrid form of Education
which I think will create higher
learning the whole objective ought to be
any one thing I'm going to do this but I
think that one would be the one would
most quickly transform the system and
all the resistors to a real focus on
student learning what is the biggest
obstacle to focusing either on student
learning or implementing digital
learning digital learning right now is
viewed as an adjunct it's like a it's
like a whiteboard and the computer
you know in the classroom you pay for it
out of a separate fund it's not at the
core of learning it's not viewed as a
core issue of learning it's viewed as a
peripheral and as such it always have
the challenges of funding and and it's
put done that way for a reason
monopolies don't want to have direct
competition imagine a repository of a
thousand quality courses that moms and
dads and teachers could access and
imagine how you share the pricing of
that depending on where you are and how
it's done in each community so it can't
be done right there's there's no model
for them anywhere online or any in any
it exists on it exists on the margins
exists as everything exists I mean this
is what reason teaches us what you all
teaches which is that markets work
monopolies resist that and so if you you
know if you're a high school and you get
seven thousand dollars per students say
a kid in Florida it's about right that's
16 you have six credits you would divide
seven thousand by six you'd get thirteen
hundred dollars or something like that
thirteen hundred dollars for that
geometry class split between the
providers of the content and the
classroom teacher and the administration
around that teacher could could easily
be handled and it would create higher
quality huge scale opportunities where
you can lower costs the other thing I'd
say is any any reform that's worth its
salt right now has to recognize that
we're in a decade-long flat per-student
spending so there are fantastic charter
schools and the big urban areas you know
we are getting 20 grand per student and
those children are going to have a great
education it completely compared to what
the alternatives are but it's not
transformative if it can't be applied at
the national average of student funding
because that's where the most propulsive
kind of changes will take place so
anything that provides higher quality
and lower costs just as it is in the
real world world will have great success
in education if when what's your time
frame for the Berlin Wall
the education monopoly being you know
just torn down by the the inmates you
know I don't know I don't know if it'll
be a dramatic wall crashing because we
have Eastern you know Eastern Europe and
eastern Germany was one entity we have
thousands of little monopolies so it's a
little bit different in that regard but
I do think that the cracks are already
starting to happen that there is a
tipping point that's beginning not for
the ultimate transform kind of system
this completely child center where money
goes with the child and you have a
myriad of public and private options but
we're making good progress on a variety
of different things accountability
school choice is expanding in most
places teacher evaluation and how you
pay teachers all that stuff is happening
so it may not be the one big explosion
where we all say I guess it's done now
what is next for you well what's next
for me is to build on this this
foundations three years old and this
conference is two times bigger than last
year and four times bigger than the year
before and I like the fact that we've
become a meeting place a gathering place
for a broad spectrum of people that have
diverse views but are really focused on
education reform I want to be a catalyst
to try to find ways for you know in a
world with great ideological fights to
be fought and I'll be part of that I
mean there are big fights to be fought
I'd like for education to be a place
where ideology doesn't drive the
decisions but but but doesn't form the
debate informs the debate and had but
it's focused I mean I think a liberal
could support systemic change sure
school choice in the 60s was a was a
creature of the left out of the right
right it makes no sense for me to think
that you have the left supporting an
unsustainable system and the right not
focusing on rising student achievement
as a high priority but just kind of
focusing on local control being the
dominant feature we need to get the
debate beyond that and I hope to play a
role in that great thank you very much
thanks for being here